[Music]
hey guys welcome back top the record
where we talk about whatever we want I
can't touch that shame I know it's one
of them and play it no it's gotta make
noise
I smell the booze Ella yeah that sounds
like something way different there you
go that's a nice smell your fingers no
these have never been washed before ever
smells disgusting okay it's not very
dusty in here though what I know I
didn't realize how much dust accumulates
until I move either like my first like
apartment and like I'd be like trying to
be I'll kimchi keeping the windows open
like all the birds fly in I'm like oh no
but I mean like I just feel like Snow
White when I have the windows open
because they're French windows that nice
la brake dust lining like this and then
I started getting the diets and I was
like no straight up in LA meant like I
was that was the probably one of the
most hardest things to adjust to because
I'm not used to having to dust my
[ __ ] place every five [ __ ] day yep
you know I mean because remember that I
had this big spot in k-town we have to
leave the windows open spots over them
we would [ __ ] get a cleaning lady for
two bucks clean the whole place next day
dust an inch thick like that I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me dude so we
just got a cleaning lady and I came on
Nikki's like so uh I was riding with the
boys and then I'm on my way home and we
had a cleaning crew crew come and
because it was supposed to like three
ladies and the cleaning the whole place
up off the team yeah like a team right
so then I called Nikki and I'm like hey
how'd it go with the cleaning people and
she's like oh my god it's a [ __ ]
disaster like it looks like [ __ ] in here
like they ain't even clean that good
like I don't even know like I had to go
look over a bunch of [ __ ] and then I get
home like expecting to see like it
looked like ass and I'm like it looks
like [ __ ] Buckingham Palace
like Nicky is that like specific on
detail stuff where she can and she's
like so I'm like what were the things
that were Tom's like hey baby it looks
great in here and she's like are you
kidding like oh and then she's like
showing me like on the mirrors like if
you look at the very top of the mirror
there's like a little smudge and then
she's like pointed like this little line
that was maybe like smaller than like a
little [ __ ] like that look at that
like that won't go away and I'm just
like like so when I clean the place up
she must think I do the shittiest in the
[ __ ] world but I never knew that but
I mean like if she doesn't have super
high expectations for it then like maybe
she needs that mad about yeah she's
paying these people that's true that's
what she says my cleaning lady man
I love my cleaning lady why which why
are you gonna talk about oh yeah agent
Malik
come over because they clean the big
office - okay but they start off with
our house and it's just a hundred bucks
each time and it's [ __ ] spotless like
it's a brand-new house yeah I'm like
Nicky to use the same people yeah so I
would go through so many different
cleaners cuz I'm like I [ __ ] hate her
with her much - yeah and then finally
like you hooked us up with your cleaners
and I'm like and they finished in 45
minutes the whole [ __ ] house now he
said they went over time and they
charged her and they didn't have three
ladies go ahead - [ __ ] she said
they're Mexican lady's wait listen
hello my people but I went through so
many of them and they can't do the [ __ ]
right and then they're Chinese on point
so they charged 100 for the whole thing
and then we gave them 120 like it - come
on pepper and now they're just $100 for
tea no 140 anything do we were 130 500
bucks
yeah and then but then that's what they
charge us now that's why I feel that
first time that's used to be them 80
bucks and then they just started going
up which I'm completely fine with
because I pay them - Lars yeah they're
really [ __ ] good for sure good
hopefully I don't do this video you're
gonna charge you our bus service yeah
hopefully that
yeah no it's not 200 what are you get by
you the first time from what you paid
them they got that's what they charge
now so we don't even put anything on top
of that I kind of want to use them no
but like my lady's more expensive but I
love her cuz she's so sweet
so all these people aren't sweet lady
she comes up to me she goes good morning
mr. David and that's all I need
she says mr. David oh my god bad man
there's cleaning people don't speak
English at all
it's just Chinese will they talk to me
and they go did you put your dogs away
okay and they start coming inside really
have a good day yeah they're even on
like this lady though she's so sweet man
like I would never be able to look at
her to say like hey I found somebody
better I feel like my heart you just
don't have to call her yeah I just don't
call it because I feel like she needs
the business she's got you by the balls
my phone yep she does says if you're
already interesting like okay turned on
by their turn it was like cuz she's not
that expensive so it's worth the money
but if she did a terrible job then I'd
be like I gotta go on but she does such
a good [ __ ] job and every time she
comes in she goes is there something new
that you want me to do or did I do
something you kind of do something
better every time she's good I will now
I will never do that again
yes and she speaks very little English
but then she could communicate that
house myself
she's a kid ahead it's a better or not
cleaning waiting cleaning lady problems
right guys it's like so relatable
everyone doesn't have a cleaning boats
have you ever taken your Lamborghini in
the dealership and like you're like hey
little streaky guys yeah one time but I
got really busy we used to do that we
don't do this well we we only do it for
deep deep cleaning like they go and they
do all the blinds cuz it's like we can
do that but then it's like menial time
okay I guess that works like we can do
it or we can hang out with Tyco up over
the weekend you know the one time I
considered getting a cleaning lady was
like I had a friend
and like I was like damn I need to do
all this cleaning I'm really busy and I
was like maybe I'll get a TaskRabbit
person like whatever and then I was like
what if I get a TaskRabbit person her
second day and I'm leaving for work the
lady will be by 10 please make sure she
gets the stove here's the thing the
reason why I get cleaning people because
I usually wouldn't but I live in a house
with three of the dudes already a
[ __ ] mess [ __ ] three stories
alright so then we what we have to do is
this is it's like I got to go through
this whole thing okay well who's gonna
clean the stairs this day at that day
and we have to split the tasks I'm not
trying to do that [ __ ] at all so it's
like how about I pay for all the [ __ ]
utilities and everything else you guys
pay for the cleaning well split it up
that way so I'm not over here suffering
paying for the Internet utilities and
everything else so that's how we did it
in the hole and it just takes up a whole
day of just cleaning and then a whole
nother day to just do laundry and then
fold the lawn and nobody ever in this
world is going dose three [ __ ] will not
clean as well if this lady at all
whatsoever they'll see like a dirt month
ago yeah take a paper down like yep got
it
I do feel like I will say that like if
you if you have somebody that does your
laundry and as you're cleaning if you're
using that at a time management sense
you're like I'm gonna sacrifice two
hundred dollars for these services I
will have seven extra hours of time I'm
gonna make sure I filled that with
productivity then it's totally worth it
just to relax let's say your week was so
busy I think one time we hired that
cleanly is early on because so can cuz
they were creating them we just have our
feet up
I felt so wila able to watch bad boys
too I felt so judged cuz like I grew up
in a household where every weekend
everyone's [ __ ] pitching in and you
clean you plug put Isis over here right
and and in my household that like you're
being judged for the theme like if your
house is [ __ ] up it's the females
fault mmm you know so when the cleaning
people came in and I'm just and I'm like
I can't be okay yeah I got a hell boy I
do this uh
and then after a while I'm like no come
on movers I can't just stand there while
other men lift [ __ ] around me I think
I'm a little [ __ ] if I do this [ __ ] I
can't I could pay them
I don't want to be that day those dudes
are [ __ ] buff dude then use like
professional movers those guys are yoked
hey no technique we have like organized
everything baby in and out this [ __ ] in
like three hours
yeah but I'm stubborn and I have to
front hard but do you really want like I
even have a friend that says like his
deals it's like don't ever ask me to
move anything for you and I will never
ask you to move anything for me
like that's how much people are like
[ __ ] that it's a great friend mmm he's
like our friendship has boundaries and
they're very did help anybody move I
like doing that [ __ ] healthier to have
friends it's about help other people
moving to move my own [ __ ] yeah it's my
son I'm just gonna hire people you
[ __ ] do but if someone wants me to
help him move out well since I moved
into our new place Nikki's added so much
heavy furniture that I'm like I am not
moving us this time and she's like I
already said I was fine with that
and I was like [ __ ] well those movers
are [ __ ] efficient as [ __ ] though
yeah like not if I help them out they're
gonna get mad at me cuz I don't know
what I'm doing right so I'll try to lift
something heavy I might listen do this
how I'm gonna do it like well dumbass
get the [ __ ] out the way let me do it
that sounds gonna happen because I don't
I'm ready to go like they just took
pre-workout or something yeah they're
[ __ ] good yeah I like me next to
these human beings I look like I was in
the hospital for 15 years in the coma
our movers are from the last time that
we moved there are these two Ukrainian
dudes the skinniest guys ever but
they're [ __ ] strong they're [ __ ]
bones or the short stubby mexican men
that can lift the refrigerator by
himself oh my god [ __ ] piano so how
the [ __ ] did you do that he goes
leverages yeah obtuse triangle right
guess hired at at like when I moved to
my new apartment the only like I moved
to everything myself cuz I just moved
like down the street except for I had to
have the mattress and the bed move so I
hired a TaskRabbit person it's just one
thing I figure like one item whatever
and so like he gets an I explain and I'm
like it and then he's like okay just
grab that corner I'm like what he had me
helping what move the bed to and I was
like
I thought that you know you poured this
yeah I think like I think like $95 notes
it for like 30 minutes of work is to get
out of here like I especially was like
hey can we get a dolly you know like I
wrote that like in the little notes and
so I'm [ __ ] walking down the street
like I need a break and he's like rah
he's like man you are tiny huh puts it
down his [ __ ] unclips a thing of
water big puts it down can we just keep
talking I'm like [ __ ] paying for that
crazy yeah I so that's my experience of
movers you must be you need to stop
looking for movers and cleaners on this
TaskRabbit yeah it's housed private
trash I guess you've been getting
trashed oh yeah so I would like somebody
to clean my house Oh my cleaning lady
what she said to me that made me feel
really good too she was like she
understands like this relationship like
trusting and then I had a leave and she
was like mr. David thank you for
trusting me with your place that you can
leave me here by myself
damn you trying to be my family or what
yeah like you try to get a Christmas
gift right now or what could you are you
huh are you gonna get em again or some
[ __ ] yeah I absolutely have to do yeah
I'm gonna get I don't even know I'm
trying to make my list of who I will
actually get Christmas gifts for and
write out the budget like bite your
mailman what about your mailman mailman
what I'm gonna get one for Mike he does
that [ __ ] that's nice ginger my mailman
oh my god mailman probably a so many
present my mailman
I had a [ __ ] I call into the [ __ ]
South Pasadena [ __ ] place because he
kept on chucking our [ __ ] or just not
even coming up oh say like my mailman
left up yeah you can package at the
garage door cuz that's what we have a
little box but it's a package and it was
like what the [ __ ] you couldn't walk to
the dude literally I saw the dude walk
up write a [ __ ] thing right saying I
wasn't there just put it on didn't you
try to go up yalll of that [ __ ]
oh yeah get the [ __ ] out a complaint
switch the drive they apologize I was
like are you [ __ ] kidding me that's
like the second time did the dish it to
like mine he like drives to my house and
will hand deliver things or like pick
things up that the return oh they do his
job is crazy I cuz I actually signed up
you know those coupons again the mail
and it just accumulates a [ __ ] ton of
trash ya hate that so much and I saw
that there's a thing where you can
unsubscribe from it so I
when online I did that this mailman
still gives me my neighbor's [ __ ]
coupons I'm okay he's on the tape dude I
read the address and it says for the
next-door dude I'm like haha thanks
still have to throw away all this [ __ ] I
hate it cuz I hate wasting all that
paper on my wife zone my apartment
building has a trash can next to the
thing just for all that yes yeah same
with us in our condo we have a garbage
can yeah I had somebody who I assumed it
must have only been at UPS what's the
man you've been USPS USPS yeah I ordered
a credit card in the mail I [ __ ] get
it I get it out of mouth I look at it
the envelope was open and taped shut
knowing the worst tape job ever like you
could see dirt on the edges of the tape
I was like are you [ __ ] kidding me so
I open it up and like I was talking to
somebody and they were like yeah make
sure you cancel that immediately but I
open it up and when I look at the paper
there's a dirty fingerprint on the [ __ ]
and so I called the like cancel it and
they're like I would say does this
happen often she was like no like
somebody literally went in wrote down my
credit card information like they had
folded up the side of the card and then
just taped it back up yeah that
fingerprint yeah I mean I did it I mean
I didn't because I was just like what
the [ __ ] but I still have the paper I'm
done anything with it that's good the
paper with the thumbprint yeah it
literally has a dirty thumb I'm gonna
give it to the forensics lab the front
does it'll probably catch that right I
don't know but I also just feel like
that's so angry you do your own forensic
I know I'm just not a snitch like look
at that yeah I'm calling snitch I was
calling yeah but they were trying to rip
you off doesn't that make you mad but
they want to try to rip me personally
off they would just try and rip off like
there are people personally they wrote
down your name
for you both attended leap start player
of the NFL bowling [ __ ] team Noah the
Chicago Cubs second baseman both yeah I
don't know if I'm not a snitch I'm a
[ __ ] snitch to the max my friend
exactly but if it's personal other
people I'll snitch the [ __ ] out of you
dude if it's personal I'm the first guy
at the police station at 5:30
I'm waiting from that open what are you
doing here oh I'm a snitch oh yeah I'm
waiting the snitch sir you guys like
ever snitched on something and like felt
bad about it no no elementary school if
some [ __ ] happened like let's say even
in elementary like you would I don't
know somebody would start some [ __ ] you
would start a fight and then like oh
what's going on here nobody would say
[ __ ] you're right
I don't snitch but then you will [ __ ]
them up after school yeah so you do your
own justice I was at a friend's birthday
party and we're all like [ __ ] around
in the backyard and we were all climbing
this fence and like I broke part of the
wooden fence like thing it like snapped
off and like fell on the ground and the
dad comes out he's all pissed and and
there's a guy that I [ __ ] hated and
he hated me and he did not snitch on me
and nobody rolled on oh [ __ ]
no hell no that's good man right there
I'm switched on like dogs like dog
owners and [ __ ] that's like my jam what
is this dude there you go I feel like I
gotta like in some situations like that
like I got a win so by wet like by
cancelling the card he didn't get [ __ ] I
win but if I go a step further it's
punishing and that's not really like my
jam you know see he didn't get it so you
didn't win do you punished him that
means you win that's my philosophy I've
seen you on Smosh you like to win you
win by letting a make a charge and you
log into the account your life
[ __ ] yeah crime committed and you have a
fingerprint already then you call it in
you cancel the car right after let them
commit the crime I guess I guess I could
be protecting my mom and you [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of her
hello yeah yeah yeah it was fraud on I
think my like Jake a credit card and
whoever used it bought a bunch of
American Eagle [ __ ] and he sent it here
what yeah they're bad people do that
just to get the points Wow who's been
frauding you you'd be friend his dad
oh we were here when we got the American
Eagle stuff yeah you take his dad drink
huh things get a little carried away you
[ __ ] that exact lectures of it
exactly and then you send him a letter
and a photograph this is how how your
dad's gay with picture of you sucking on
in the dance you're sucking his dick
yeah yeah you're sucking that's scary
like I like a mask but then no now
you're like oh I got you back bud yeah
that guy's crazy like he [ __ ] my dad
that's [ __ ] crazy and then you don't
want to tell anybody about that you're
like why'd you shoot that guy out he
[ __ ] my dad you didn't tell anybody
that you can't I'm like I got you so
good sounds like some kind of porno
though they sound less important it does
sound like some porn is that what you
watch no no no no no we watch that story
story base stuff like we got to get the
storyline that's why I was saying before
maybe some females you don't okay you
guys don't you got okay see what are you
what are you guys like the fast-forward
we're not a get to the [ __ ] juicy
part yeah I like the story I like a
little I like the dialogues on my [ __ ]
you can you go I don't want to hear the
[ __ ] dialogue but that's writing is
horrible like I don't know wait I
thought we all women think exactly the
same cause if you're just women then
you're all the same
well exactly that's what we just proved
[Laughter]
the story part of pornography is really
boring right cuz don't you want to just
get any gas always [ __ ] terrible
watching the whole thing I need some
people like story stuff because they're
they're certainly not a stories like the
person I like oh I don't know character
and I want to see them give spot to wake
up with it but there's no there's no way
that that's just Britain where you're
attached to the character cuz it's so
quick just like no hey I'm looking for a
house well that's funny if you sucked my
dick it pretty good looking for a house
well if you suck my dick and eat some
come I could drop the price see that see
that's what I'm saying y'all are
watching the 13 minute pornhub versions
where it's like hi
hey nice [ __ ] suck on it right you
smell this [ __ ] no but I'm saying if I
did again but like no so it like those
are like the 32 minute ones where like
they draw it out you in an imposing tin
you've been caught
32 minute of story and the [ __ ] part
is in your favorite I mean like but now
okay okay save it this way no I can't do
that either
I don't mind saying this cuz I feel like
some people may relate there are some
people that literally can't like sleep
with somebody unless they have an
emotional attachment to them so I don't
want to see certain porn unless a few
unless these characters have an
emotional that's weird you know what
guys can't do that though you know what
you know what guys can't do that though
because the only way a guy can do that
[ __ ] is if the port happens in 15
minutes right the sucking and the
[ __ ] that means my dick would have to
rise in 15 minutes as well yeah cuz I
guarantee you right when it clicks on
its already up so it has to do a slow
50-minute rise mmm have you seen big
sausage pizza grants porn site may be
known a man ever
oh it's like pre-paint brothers whatever
right yeah yeah so this is like the
early days right we're cut a little hole
and it's think they cut a hole in the
pizza and that guy's six addicting
artists after a while when I wanted for
pizza yeah and then she starts sucking
on it and then sometimes the dude picks
are up and [ __ ] her with the pizza box
is like a slap up against their button
shake because they glued it down or
whatever but what the funniest thing
about that series sometimes you love me
seasons that deserve to know sometimes
they would get like clearly a delivery
pizza and then sometimes they would get
like a DiGiorno pizza tombstone pizza
but it's like why sometimes did they get
delivery pizza and why sometimes do they
get frozen if you're helping me out
apparently I get paid a dollar
no no I didn't even mention nothing
about the series I don't give a [ __ ]
about the brand but no it's funny that
it's it's just funny to see the
different types of pizza you're like oh
that's clearly
oh yeah what an observation you're so
[ __ ] observe it thank you for
pointing that out
just picture seven pieces of pepperoni
on a girl's ass yeah and then sometimes
they get Hawaiian and then sometimes
it's like what what did your if the
directors like this one has to be BBQ
chicken pizza the BBQ chicken pizza
give me a barbecue chicken beats you
know I mean like why that's my favorite
funny like in the scene he's supposed to
like eat out her [ __ ] but he's so
hungry because he hasn't been getting
the pepperoni on her ass raw [ __ ] eat
her [ __ ] already I can't I'm [ __ ]
starving dude the pepperoni
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]